Moi: Bonjour!
En cette période d'Halloween.
Oui.
Encore.
Je voulais vous parler d'un sujet cool:
la sorcellerie.
En restant dans le domaine historique, bien
sûr.
Cependant en faisant mes petites recherches,
je me suis dit qu'il serait judicieux de commencer
par vous présenter l'Inquisition, même si
elle ne s'est pas cantonnée à la condamnation
de la sorcellerie, parce que c'est super intéressant.
L'Inquisition a dans l'imaginaire populaire
une image de violence, de justice arbitraire
et de bûchers enflammés.
Et c'était vrai! Merci au revoir!
-Euuuuh...
-Ok, c'est faux.
Ces idées reçues sont en partie le fait
d'Etienne Léon de Lamothe-Langon, qui écrit
une Histoire de l'Inquisition de France en
1811 basée sur des archives inédites, la
7e va vous étonner.
Quand un pseudo historien prétend avoir accès
à des super archives de fou que personne
n'avait jamais vues avant, souvent, ça sent
un peu le roussi.
Dans ce livre il montre les crimes des inquisiteurs,
qui sont très très méchants face à des
hérétiques très gentils...
Et c'est de la CONNERIE, ses soit-disant archives
inédites n'ont jamais existé et ce cher
Etienne faisait partie de la mouvance anti-cléricale
de l'époque: l’Église c'est nul, pourrissons
l’Église.
-On n'est pas chez HBO.
-L'Inquisition pontificale, donc, est une
institution créée par l’Église.
-Sans déconner.
-Je ne parlerai pas de l'Inquisition Espagnole,
d'ailleurs, parce que c'est pas vraiment la
même chose.
Voilà.
L'Inquisition qui nous intéresse est créée
vers 1231 dans le but de sauver les âmes
des chrétiens face aux crises que l’Église
traverse.
Dès la fin du XIIe siècle l’Église commence
à être critiquée par les populations.
Elles ne font plus trop confiance aux membres
du clergé parce que ce sont quand même des
gens normaux à la base, beaucoup ont été
mariés avant de devenir clercs, on ne parle
pas encore d'ordre à part.
Et bref ces messieurs tout le monde pourraient
vivre du travail des autres sans que ça choque
personne? Eh bien si, ça choque.
La littérature populaire commence à répandre
des idées de corruption et de cupidité du
clergé, ce qui complique un peu le travail
de l’Église.
En plus de ça apparaissent des mouvements
hérétiques: mais où va-t-on?
On peut distinguer deux mouvements principaux
qui sont condamnés par l’Église et jugés
par les tribunaux inquisitoriaux: les vaudois
et les cathares.
Les vaudois apparaissent vers 1170 sous l'impulsion
de Pierre Valdès, originaire de Lyon, qui
prône le retour à la pauvreté pour les
clercs.
Au début ce qu'il fait ne déplaît pas trop,
il fait traduire l'Ancien Testament...
Mais finalement ce qu'il fait est un peu trop
hardcore pour l’Église.
Il autorise des femmes à prêcher et en plus
son mouvement n'a aucune hiérarchie, une
seule messe obligatoire dans l'année...
-Venez comme vous êtes!
-Il est excommunié en 1184, puis tous les
vaudois sont condamnés en 1215 et se dispersent
dans l'Est de la France, en Italie et en Germanie.
Les Cathares se trouvent dans le Languedoc
dès le XIIe siècle aussi, ils sont un peu
plus extrêmes que les vaudois car ils condamnent
le mariage, la consommation de chair animale,
reconnaissent aux laïcs le droit de prêcher
et rejettent certains textes et idées de
l’Église: l'Ancien Testament, la résurrection
de Jésus par exemple, rien que ça.
Ils sont excommuniés dès 1119.
Les Juifs vivant en France, par contre, sont
très peu persécutés par l'Inquisition contrairement
aux idées reçues.
Ils ne sont pas considérés comme des hérétiques,
ils ont juste une autre religion.
-Il faut pas croire, ils sont quand même
persécutés par les autorités politiques.
Voire même expulsés du pays.
Par exemple, à partir de 1269 ils doivent
porter un signe distinctif sur leurs vêtements.
-Les persécutions à leur encontre prennent
un nouvel essor à partir du XIIe siècle
où on les accuse de meurtres rituels de chrétiens.
Mais tout cela est une autre histoire, et
comme je le disais les Inquisiteurs s'intéressent
très peu à eux.
Au XIIe siècle ce sont surtout les autorités
politiques de chaque pays qui se chargent
des problèmes d'hérésie, mais pour le Pape
il n'est pas question de rater tout le fun.
En 1198, il affirme que l'hérésie est un
crime de lèse-majesté divine.
-C'est un petit peu grave.
-Dans chaque paroisse sont désignés un commissionnaire,
un prêtre et quelques laïcs qui s'engagent
à dénoncer les hérétiques et pour les
juger il confie du pouvoir à des hommes nouveaux
issus des ordres mendiants.
Des moines, quoi.
Petit à petit leur statut passe au dessus
de celui de l'évêque, ils sont nommés directement
par le Pape.
Le premier est Etienne de Saint-Thibéry,
en 1234.
Il y a quelques règles pour rentrer dans
l'Inquisition: il faut avoir au moins 40
ans, être intelligent, pur de mœurs, honnête,
et s'y connaître en droit théologique et
canon.
Certains inquisiteurs écrivent aussi des
petits manuels du parfait Inquisiteur pour
épater leurs amis.
image: l'Inquisiteur pour les nuls
Comment ça se passe concrètement?
L'Inquisiteur est responsable d'un vaste territoire,
alors quand il arrive quelque part il commence
par se présenter au seigneur local pour s'assurer
qu'il va l'aider dans sa tâche et lui demander
s'il connaîtrait pas déjà deux-trois hérétiques
sur ses terres.
-Ah ben oui, y'a l'père Mathieu! Hérétiques
de père en fils *sourire*
-Ensuite il peut poursuivre directement les
hérétiques déjà connus, ou bien faire
une grande tournée à travers le territoire
durant laquelle il prêche dans les églises
et invite les hérétiques à venir se confesser
à lui.
Ne manquez pas la tournée du grand inquisiteur,
à … le 25 mai, à … le 27 et à … le
29! Entrée gratuite dans l’Église, réductions
sur les peines de mort et d'emprisonnement
si vous venez vous confesser de vous-même!
-En effet, si des hérétiques viennent se
confesser dans le délai imparti par l'Inquisiteur
ils ne risquent ni la peine de mort ni l'emprisonnement
mais peuvent être bannis ou excommuniés.
Le but de l'Inquisiteur est d'aider les personnes,
de les remettre dans le droit chemin, et pas
de les enfoncer.
Ces tournées se raréfient à partir du XIIIe
siècle où elles sont remplacées par des
poursuites individuelles.
On peut répondre devant l'inquisiteur à
partir de 14 ans pour les garçons et 12 ans
pour les filles
-Ça correspond à l'âge légal pour se marier
chez nous!
-Pour qu'une personne soit citée devant l'Inquisiteur,
il faut d'abord qu'elle soit dénoncée, anonymement,
pour éviter les représailles.
Ensuite le curé lui fait savoir qu'elle est
convoquée, et l'annonce publiquement durant
la messe pour bien lui mettre l'affiche.
Une fois qu'il comparaît, il est interrogé.
Il doit d'abord jurer sur l'évangile, et
s'il ne le fait pas ça fait déjà peser
pas mal de soupçons sur lui puisque les vaudois
et les cathares avaient interdiction de jurer.
-On va commencer l'interrogatoire, veuillez
jurer.
-Non, je refuse.
-Ok.
Vous êtes hérétique, alors.
-Non.
-Alors jurez.
-J'ai pas envie.
-Hhhhhh...
Ça commence bien.
-Le but de l'interrogatoire est d'obtenir
des aveux, ça passe par des questions mais
éventuellement aussi par le jeûne ou la
privation de sommeil.
La torture n'est pas autorisée au début
et n'est jamais employée en premier recours,
mais elle est progressivement autorisée dans
les cas où on avait déjà de sérieux doutes
à partir du milieu du XIIIe siècle.
Certains inquisiteurs continuent de la trouver
inefficace, d'autres en abusent...
En tout cas, ils en parlent peu dans leurs
manuels.
Les aveux donnés sous la torture ne sont
pas recevables, donc ils doivent être renouvelés
24h après.
Une fois l'interrogatoire terminé, l'hérétique
peut soit abjurer ses fautes, dire qu'il ne
se rendait pas compte...
Soit persévérer dans ses croyances.
Dans le premier cas il peut être condamné
à effectuer un pèlerinage, à la prison,
ou à porter un signe distinctif.
-Et s'il ne le porte pas, c'est le bûcher:)
-L'inquisiteur ne prononce pas les peines
tout seul, il réunit pour cela un conseil.
Le jugement est prononcé en public, à l'église.
Par contre si l'hérétique ne renonce pas
à ses pratiques, c'est la mort.
Mais l'Inquisiteur ne peut pas prononcer de
peine de mort, ce n'est pas un juge.
-Comment faire alors?!
-On le refile aux autorités locales avec
les instructions qui vont bien, et on organise
un grand feu de joie en public...
Alors d'après les sources que j'ai lues,
on entassait des fagots jusqu'à sa tête,
ce qui ne correspond pas vraiment à ce qu'on
voit au cinéma mais je trouvais ce détail
amusant...
-Amusant?!
-INTERESSANT à préciser.
C'est aussi la famille du condamné qui doit
payer le coût du bûcher.
La peine de mort pour hérésie reste une
mesure exceptionnelle par rapport à toutes
les autres peines appliquées.
A partir des années 1330 l'hérésie se passe
de mode et les pauvres inquisiteurs se retrouvent
au bord du chômage technique.
Comment relancer leur activité? En surfant
sur la vague de la mode encore une fois.
En pénurie d'hérétiques? Découvrez les
sorcières! Plus populaires, plus malfaisantes,
plus faciles à brûler: n'attendez plus
et commandez vos premières sorcières au
36 15 Sabbat ou sur MaleusMaleficarum.fr
Offre valable dans toute l'Europe.
L'idée qu'il existe des sorciers et sorcières
se développe en même temps qu'apparaît
le démon.
En effet le diable n'a pas toujours eu une
part importante dans les croyances chrétiennes,
mais à partir du XIIIe siècle on le voit
PARTOUT, dans les légendes, les illustrations...
Et on commence à se dire que ces petites
bonnes femmes qui guérissent à partir de
plantes ou font de la divination pourraient
tenir leurs pouvoirs du démon! C'est donc
de l'hérésie!
-De nouveaux hérétiques à brûler!
-Oui parce que quand il s'agit de sorcières
ou sorciers, on s'embête pas à les emprisonner,
imaginez qu'ils influenceraient leurs geôliers.
Mieux vaut un bon bûcher.
Les sorciers sont accusés d'avoir renié
la foi, de maudire le baptême, d'adorer le
diable, de copuler avec lui, de vouer à son
idole leurs enfants, de lui sacrifier ceux
des autres, de pratiquer le cannibalisme,
de faire mourir les bons et leur bétail,
de faire pourrir les fruits de la terre.
Le procès des sorcières est à peu de choses
près le même que celui des hérétiques
classiques, à quelques choses près: on
a plus souvent recours à la torture avec
elles.
On pense aussi qu'elles portent une marque
du diable sur le corps qui annulerait leur
baptême, alors les inquisiteurs la recherchent.
Partout.
On invente aussi le supplice de l'eau, qui
est assez connu et qui s'explique par le fait
que comme elles ont rejeté leur baptême,
on pense qu'elles ne peuvent pas être immergées:
rien à voir avec le poids d'un canard, donc.
On les balance donc à l'eau attachées à
un caillou et si elles coulent, c'est qu'elles
sont innocentes.
Dans ce cas on les remonte grâce à la corde
à laquelle elles étaient attachées.
On n'est pas des barbares !
Bon, si par un quelconque hasard elles flottent...
Pas de chance.
Je réaliserai un autre épisode entièrement
consacré à la sorcellerie plus tard, où
cette fois on ne s'attardera pas sur la manière
dont se déroulaient les procès mais sur
les croyances de l'époque.
L'Inquisition pontificale est créée en 1231
et décline dès les années 1270, avec le
déclin des hérésies.
Les Inquisiteurs se tournent alors vers la
sorcellerie mais ne sont déjà plus aussi
actifs, et ils disparaissent définitivement
au XVIIIe siècle.
Puisque les sorcières succèdent aux hérétiques,
il est intéressant de noter que le vocabulaire
se mélange: je vous avais parlé des vaudois,
les hérétiques originaires de Lyon.
Eh bien à partir du XIVe siècle le terme
de «vauderie» devient un synonyme de
sorcellerie.
Voilà.
J'espère que l'histoire de l'Inquisition
vous a intéressés, si vous voulez en savoir
plus je vous recommande le livre de Didier
le Fur, L'Inquisition, qui est pas très gros
et facile à lire.
Je vous retrouve dans peu de temps pour un
épisode des Créatrices du Tube un peu en
lien avec ce sujet.
Je n'en dis pas plus.
Merci d'être nombreux à me regarder, on
a dépassé
les 3000 dernièrement et c'est beaucoup.
Merci, et à bientôt!